rhenium is in the same group as
manganese in the periodic table but
quite surprisingly it was only
discovered in 1925 so my father was 15
years old when it was discovered so it's
a very recent discovery compared to many
of the other elements I think because
it's quite rare and it is also quite
hard to separate rhenium let's look at
the rhenium looks like so this is a
sample of rhenium okay this is a very
very nice metal often used in catalysis
from the middle of the transition metal
group and here you see the very very
dark black coloration of this very very
fine wire of rhenium so I'd never seen a
sample of metallic rhenium until about a
month ago when I was given some as a
present so here's the sample it's quite
a nice silvery metal and what surprising
is that it's really very heavy because
elements low down on the periodic table
are very dense and we can demonstrate
this by weighing it let me compare the
rhenium with the pile of five American
10 cent pieces five dimes so this is
half a dollar and you can see this is
bigger than that considerably so if we
weigh the coins you can see it weighs
just a bit more than 11 grams eleven
point three grams which is quite
reasonable because they're made out of
copper and nickel and if we now take
these off and put on the rhenium which
is a smaller lump of metal you can see
that it weighs more than 16 grams so
it's a really very dense metal we give
someone a little little shot of rhenium
as a present so this comes from the
managing director
Nicoll Lippmann who make or supply rare
metals and he came to give me an
interview for a magazine and he gave me
a sample of this element so I was really
excited he gave it to me in this bag
together with the analysis of the
element and it's 99.9% pure and inside
is a piece of paper with the complete
analytical data I was really very
excited and especially because I was not
expecting a present
we're always taught metals in the same
group of the periodic table like
manganese and rhenium are very similar
so I was expecting that the salts of
rhenium would be very similar to the
salts of manganese but I was really
surprised when I was told that the
company also supplied a salt per renate
so I already knew that the manganese
salt permanganate had this terrific
purple color so here you can see it
dissolved in water and next to it you
can see the solid that's almost black so
these are manganese salts so I was
expecting a terrific color from the
rhenium salt and the rhenium salt is a
really boring white this is per renate
with rhenium in it and the reason why
it's white which I understood afterwards
is because the color comes from the
energy of the electrons in the iron and
in rhenium the difference in energy
between the different levels for the
electron is much bigger so instead of
absorbing visible light and looking
colored it absorbs ultraviolet light
which we don't notice so big
disappointment
Perrine 8 is white rhenium in recent
years has become an extremely important
element for making aircraft engine
particularly jet engines and aircraft
and at the same time as giving me this
sample of rhenium I was given this
object here this is a turbine blade from
the front end of a really quite
sophisticated jet engine now it's a used
turbine blade and you can see there's a
large slot has been cut in it to stop
people selling this used blade to be put
back into jet engines so this is right
in the middle of the engine just after
the combustion chamber where the fuel
has burnt so the temperature is very
high and this is spinning round very
fast so there are enormous stresses on
this metal the temperature is probably
about 1,600 degrees centigrade or even
higher and most metals were just melt or
they would become so floppy they would
stretch as they spun round and this is
made from a special alloy which has
quite a lot of nickel in it but the
magic ingredient is rhenium that makes
it stronger but what I find particularly
surprising about this is that this whole
blade is a single crystal of metal
because if you have a lump of metal the
weak part is between the different
crystals that make up the lump but if
you grow a single crystal it has no
weaknesses and it's very very much
stronger so this is an amazing piece of
engineering because if you look closely
you can see it's Hollow
so they have grown a single crystal
which has a hole inside so they can blow
air through it to keep it cool to stop
it getting quite as hot as it might do
otherwise and so the lamp of rhenium
that I was given actually came from
recycled turbine blades because really
is quite a rare element and once you put
them in the turbine blades when you
service the engine you get the turbine
blades back and you can recycle the
rhenium metal and if we didn't do that
it would soon run out because there
aren't very large supplies of rhenium in
the longer term rhenium may have quite
useful applications in a variety of
solar cells and perhaps as catalysts for
splitting water into hydrogen and oxygen
but at the moment the major technical
application is in making these special
alloys
it is called rhenium because it was
discovered in Germany and the rhenium is
derived from the name of the River Rhine
which flows through Germany there are
other rivers in Germany though wide the
Rhine get I have no idea